Musik
Musik Die erste Regel, es gibt keine Regeln. Kurze irritierte Pause. nichts Selbstreferentielles, keine Pausen entstehen lassen, viertens Ensemble denken, also wir lassen uns ausregen gegenseitig, wir haben ein Ja und Denken im Gegensatz zu sonst wo wir ein Nein und ich weiß es besser Denken haben. Mit diesen Regeln steigen wir jetzt ein in den zweiten Teil der Folge, die wir gestern begonnen haben, eine Brückenfolge, die wir zum ersten Mal aufnehmen. Ich würde sagen, wir fangen eine ganz neue Folge nochmal an und machen einen grossen Mashup. Die Folge beginnt, wir sehen Weiss, das Nichts, wir hören nichts, noch ist nichts geschehen, die Schöpfung hat noch nicht angefangen, doch plötzlich wir sehen ein helles Licht, ein helles Licht, das im Weiss auf uns zu, was nicht so doll ist, im Weiss ist nicht so deutlich. Es ist so ein Energiesparmodus-Licht. Es … Auf uns zu. Was nicht so doll ist, weil es im Weiss ist nicht so deutlich. Es ist ein glimmendes Licht. Es ist so ein Energiesparmodus Licht. Es kommt auf uns zu. Es kommt immer näher. Hören wir dazu etwas? Ja, die Musik von The Magnificent Seven. Die Hörbehinderung leuchten. Okay, das Licht kommt weiter auf uns zu. Wir sehen, es verwandelt sich in einen … Raben. Raben, in einen weissen Raben. Schwarzen Raben. Und dann? Und jetzt fliegt der aber auf uns zu. Wir sehen, es verwandelt sich in einen Raben, in einen weissen Raben. Schwarzen
Raben. Und dann? Und jetzt fliegt der aber auf uns zu. Du stehst ein bisschen vor mir. Herzlich
willkommen, sehr geehrte Damen und Herren, bei Das Podcast UFO. Folge Nummer keine Abo, wissen
wir nicht. Aber was wir wissen ist, dass mir gegenüber sitzt nichts geringerer als Stefan, Stefan, Stefan, Tizla, Silon, Aromayalomon.
Gegenüber von mir heute, das war übrigens gerade Hebräisch, sitzt kein geringer als Florentin. Ich? Ich? Hilf mir schnell, Will. Ja, genau. Wie geht's dir, Florentin? Danke für diese kleine, nette Einschicksware. Mir geht's tatsächlich sehr gut, ich hab heute den ganzen Tag sehr viel gegessen, das heisst, ich hab sehr viel Energie. Du hast fünf, ich war dabei den ganzen Tag, ich habe es gesehen, du hast fünf Hähnchen gegessen. Nein, stimmt, ich habe eineinhalb Hähnchen. Ich habe eineinhalb halbe Hähnchen gegessen, was mich schon an die Grenze meiner mathematischen Kapazitäten bringt. Zwei dritte. Insgesamt habe ich ein, zwei dritte Hähnchen gegessen. Durch drei im Sinn mal Pi ist Fettleibigkeit. Das ist eine Fettleibigkeit Adipositas 3, glaube ich, in hoch zwei, sowas in der Richtung.
Und deswegen haben wir eine Menge Energie für diese tolle Folge. P-Huhn-Formel, die P-Huhn-Formel. Wow, viel zu spät und nicht so gut. Also ich habe alle Regeln gebrochen der Comedy. Aber es gibt ja diese Regel, dass du das Volumen einer Pizza, die Formel ist genau Pizza. Ja, ich glaube nicht.
Da hast du in so einem Fiebertraum geträumt, als du gerade den ganzen Tag in so einem Pizzakarton gelebt hast. Pi, also P-I mal Z mal Z mal A. Ja, wenn du den Durchmesser halt Z nennst, dann ist es Z und A ist, glaube ich, die Fläche. Wenn du alles anders nennst und das Ergebnis dann noch so abziehbar, wenn es in eine Pizza rauskommt, dann ergibt es Pizza. Ja, dann ist auch die Mitternachtsformel Heil Hitler tatsächlich. Clever. Mir ist eben was aufgefallen an dir. Du bist der einzige Mensch, der den USB-Stick, bevor er ihn einsteckt, anguckt, dass du ihn sofort richtig einsteckst. Jetzt führt mich zu der Frage, was... Ich habe schlechte Erfahrungen. Ich habe schlechte Erfahrungen. Ja, aber genau, das wurde das Trauma in deiner Vergangenheit, Kindheit schätze ich mal. Kindheit tatsächlich. Deine Mutter war ein Uwe-Grosser oder ein USB-Stick oder was genau. Ja, richtig. Ich frage mich jetzt, kostet das Zeit, wenn du das zuerst falsch einsteckst, mehr als es erst anzugucken und dann richtig reinzustecken direkt? Nee, ich bin ein sehr ordentlicher Mensch und ich denke mir einfach, ich möchte Taten, die ich tue, gerne perfekt machen und deswegen schaue ich nach, wie die Parameter gestellt sind. Wir sind ein reibungsloser Mensch. Ein komplett reibungsloser Mensch. R ist gleich Null, was mich angeht. Die mathematische Folge heute mal ein bisschen. Ich habe gelernt, es ist meistens nicht der Anfangsbuchstabe, wofür das steht. Also R ist Radius, Reibung ist gross R. Reibung ist glaube ich, ich glaube, Das Q oder so ist Reibung, V ist Geschwindigkeit. Glaubst du, Reibung heisst Reibung, weil so ein reibendes R. Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich hätte damals in meinem Deutschunterricht die Vermutung aufgestellt, der ging zum Sprach und wie die Sprache entwickelt. Und ich habe noch keinen Gag entdeckt. Doch, ich habe den Gag entdeckt. Fünfte Klasse, so, was kommt nach dem D im Alphabet,
Kleiner Stefan meldet sich, also folgendes, ich habe Reibung, glaube ich,
die aufgestellt, dass Worte generell so klingen, wie die Dinge, die sie benennen.
Nee, es war Leistungskursdeutsch, Leistungskursdeutsch.
Du hattest Leistungskursdeutsch erzählen.
Ja, und dann ging es darum, wie Sprache entstehen, und dann hatten wir schon sehr viele Unterrichtseinheiten darüber gemacht,
und dann habe ich irgendwann behauptet, ja, aber manchmal ist es doch einfach auch so,
es klingt etwas schön wie eine Sonne, es klingt wie eine Sonne. Deswegen hat man Sonne genannt. Und wir haben mir ein paar Leute zugestimmt und der Lehrer meinte, ja, wir waren schon ein bisschen weiter. Das ist schon bio jetzt, Stefan. Das ist schon demütig. So einfach, das ist das Schlechteste, es ist nicht nur falsch, wir waren schon wesentlich weiter. Wir haben den Fehler auch schon vor vier Sitzungen korrigiert. Das war der gleiche Lehrer, wo ich behauptet habe, da ging es um berühmte Maler und ich habe Monet mit Merlot verwechselt und habe behauptet, aber wirklich standfest behauptet, er hiesse Merlot, der Maler. Bilbo Beutlin und Medlock. Nein, sie hießen nicht, die hießen nicht behauptet, der hieß Merlot, der berühmte Expressionist. Impressionist. Weiss man auch nicht so genau, das sind auch so Dinge, die man einfach komplett austauschen kann. Es gibt ja drei an von Genies. Florentin Felix Will. Ja, wer ist Felix? Das ist die grosse Frage. Bist du hier ein zweiter Name? Ähm, ja. Felix Dietmar tatsächlich ist mein zweiter Name. War das der lustigste Name, der dir gerade eingefallen ist? Ja, ich würde schon sagen. Ich bin ganz zufrieden eigentlich mit dem, was mein Gehirn mir so... Ich mache mir so eine Schublade auf und immer so ein Moment der Hoffnung, was ist drin und oft fehlt der Boden einfach und ich gucke durch und gar nichts passiert. Entweder ist es ein Ohm oder ein Ohm. Ach, da habe ich das liegen gelassen. Auch eine schöne Metapher fürs Unterbewusstsein, wenn du mal da irgendwie... Da gibt es ja einen Film, Inside Out, ich weiss nicht, ob du den schon mal gesehen hast, genau das gleiche eigentlich. Nicht wirklich, da geht es weniger um Möbel. Steel like a Florentin will. Nee, ich würde den Pixar-Film komplett über Möbel machen. Da gibt's Stuhli, den kleinen naiven Stuhl, der dann irgendwann sich verliebt. Gab's in Disney auch schon mal, da bei Schön und das Biest haben alle Möbel irgendwie gesprochen. Nein, ein Kerzenständer ist kein Möbel. Keep it on rolling, ich bin gespannt, was jetzt kommt. Nein, nein, nein, ein Kerzenständer ist kein Möbel. Was ist ein Möbel? Lass uns mal über Möbel reden. Die Ursünde des Podcasts, wo die katastrophale Folge sieben. Okay, du hast eine Regel gebrochen. Ach, scheiße! Also nichts selbstreferenzielles, du bist auf diverse Folgen eingegangen. Gerade schon. Auf eine Folge, Möbel. Aber zum Beispiel ist ein Bett ein Möbel. Ist das Bettgestell? Ist das ein Möbel? Ja, nee, ich würde es in Toto, die ich quasi mit Matratze würde ich singen.
Weinst du das Musical?
Nein, ich meine die Band mit Africa.
Wenn du Musical im Publikum sitzt, singst du da eigentlich mit? Habe ich mich oft gefragt und ich habe meistens herausgefunden, dass Aufstehen, Mitklatschen und die Choreografie mit nachmachen wollen der falsche Weg ist. Vor allem wenn du das komplette Löwenkostüm an hast natürlich, in Solid Express ist es natürlich nicht so perfekt. Kam nicht gut an. Ne, aber tatsächlich, bei welchen Aktivitäten ist es vom Publikum erwünscht, dass sie mitmachen und bei welchen nicht? Ich denke mir zum Beispiel immer, ich denke mir zum Beispiel immer, meine gesamte Frage, brisantes Thema, ich bin gespannt, wo es hinführt. Ich denke mir, bei jeder Situation, in der bei musikalischen Darbietungen das Publikum mitklatscht, denke ich, warum denkt ihr, dass ihr mitklatschen sollt? Was soll das? Weil das Publikum insgesamt denkt, es sollte schneller sein, das Lied. Und dann machen wir ein bisschen Dampf. Schneller, ich muss nach Hause, muss nach Hause. Ja, auch dieses Mitsingen bei Konzerten verstehe ich nicht. Ich bin da, um die Band zu hören. Auch wenn die Band dann sowas macht wie Und jetzt Stuttgart, singt jetzt mit mir! Dann will ich absolute Schweigen, stille! Happy Birthday! Den gröslichen Song Happy Birthday. Und dann will ich aber, ich bin ja da, um Florentinville and the Machines zu hören, wie sie ihren Hit Happy Birthday to All of You singen. Und ich finde es immer ein bisschen faul vom Publikum, Weil wir als Gag-Autoren stehen ja auch nicht vor dem Publikum und sagen dann, kommt ein Mann zum Hautarzt und jetzt hier und jetzt hier, das will niemand machen. Das ist eigentlich ganz geil für eine Comedy-Show eigentlich, so ein bisschen Crowd-Crow-Works. Es ist eigentlich genau das gleiche, was eine Band macht, nur auf ein anderes Business übertragen. Also ich verstehe nicht, was Bands in den Kram passt. Aber gibt es Comedians, die, weil Comedians oft, wenn sie Zugaben geben sollen, dann sagen sie
nochmal Bits, äh, alte Bits, die sich Leute auch wünschen.
Mit alten Bits meinen sie der Erste des Abends halt.
Genau, und dann performen die nochmal und vielleicht reden da manchmal auch Publikumsleute mit
oder sprechen die Pointe mit oder sowas. Ich frage mich nur immer bei diesen ganzen Musikdingern,
ob dann, weil ich meine, die ganzen Instrumente müssen ja aufeinander abgestimmt sein, damit es gut zusammenklingt, ob die das schon mit einberechnen, dass das Publikum mitklatscht, weil dadurch ist ja die Rhythmusfraktion wesentlich stärker als alle anderen. Da muss der Bass ja sagen, ja Leute, jetzt hört man den Bass nicht mehr, also lass uns den Bass von Anfang an lauter machen. Ich weiß nur, dass Tonmenschen das Publikum mit einberechnen, sehr zerbrechlich sind, ja und Aus Ton, und meistens blind sind. Aber das ist eine andere, traurigere Geschichte. Aber die berechnen, wenn sie eine Halle aussteuern, zum Beispiel die Längs-Hass-Arena, dann berechnen sie das Publikum mit ein. Also die setzen ganz viele Mehlsäcke da hin. Weil das Publikum absorbiert ja Ton in die Herzen. Absorbiert. Die absorbieren es im Herzen und nehmen es dann den Künstlern in gewisser Weise weg und das müssen die Musiker dann mehr leisten, sozusagen. Weisst du, dass wenn man stirbt, der Körper 21 Gramm leichter wird plötzlich? Das stimmt aber nicht. Doch, der grosse Alejandro G. Inerrito. González Inerritoito. Gonzalo G. Inerito. Hat einen Film darüber gemacht.
Wenn es einen Film über etwas gibt, dann ist es auf jeden Fall wahr.
Ja.
Siehe Sherlock Holmes.
Siehe Eight Mile.
Siehe König der Löwe.
Ja, weil es schon mal gefallen ist heute, oder?
Ja, ich glaube auch. Wir hatten beide den gleichen Impuls.
Aber ich habe tatsächlich, ich verstehe nie, warum Leute überhaupt mitmachen bei Dingen, die sie sehen. Warum müssen sie sich selber so mit einbringen? Denken sie, die helfen den Musikern? Oder denken sie, das ist so jetzt, dadurch zeigen sie, dass ihnen gefällt, was gerade passiert? Ja, gute Frage. Ich frage mich auch immer, wir sind ja auch zwei Menschen, die gerne im Mittelpunkt stehen. Das würden wir ja auch gerade nicht machen. Aber ich hätte nie Bock, irgendwie im Zirkus oder so, als ich noch kleiner war, auf die Bühne gezogen zu werden. Ja, ich habe mich immer versteckt. Oder ich hätte auch oftmals in der Kirche eine bisschen unbegründete Angst, aber auch in der Kirche auf die Bühne gezogen sein, um irgendwie mitzusingen. Ich hätte auch mal Angst, Fürbitten vorzulesen. Das war ganz unangenehm. So an Orten, wo man ist, um zuzuschauen, wollte ich nie auf die Bühne gezogen werden. Du hast damals auch bei unserem Stand-Up-Auftritt immer gesagt, das stand in der Bühne und bitte nicht, ich, bitte nicht, ich, bitte nicht. Und hier ist Stefan Titzel! Nein, fuck! Das hast du gut gemacht, das hast du gut gemacht. Ich bin immer noch stolz auf dich. Einmal ein cooler Moment, ne? Ja, war ein cooler Moment. Ach, ich finde es ist ein nicht schlechtes Konzept, ich würde es auch gerne öffnen, gerade den Zuhörer, dass wir jetzt zwei Tage nacheinander aufgenommen haben und es einfach zusammenschneiden. Wir mischen es einfach zusammen. Wir waren nicht zufrieden mit der ersten Folge. Und sind mit dieser Folge auch nicht zufrieden. Doch. Deswegen dachten wir uns, zwei Mittelmässige ergeben ein gutes. Jetzt verlässt mich gerade. Geht immer weiter. Nicht abhusten. Das ist der grösste Fehler. Nicht abhusten. Es liegt kaum noch die Potenzial da. Da muss ich mich jetzt echt ein bisschen dagegen wehren, dass ich... Es ist wie die, kratze ich nicht, dann muss man sich kratzen. Hallo, mein Lieber, hallo, da ist er wieder, er ist zurückgekommen. Huste bitte ab. Danke. Na, ist gut. Das ist sehr gut. Mir hat es gut gefallen. Es gibt drei Arten von Genies. Ja, man kann ja den Griff des Genius, kann man ja unterteilen in drei verschiedene Arten des Genies. Und ich möchte dich bitten, zu entscheiden, in welche der drei Arten Genius du mich einordnen würdest. Einfach damit ich da ein bisschen Klarheit habe. Ich möchte kurz dem Hörer, die nicht so gedanklich schnell sind wie ich, kurz offenlegen, dass diesem Satz, dieser Frage, die Prämisse zugrunde liegt, dass er einer dieser drei Genies ist. Die Frage ist welcher. Ich habe dazu als Anschauungsbeispiele drei anerkannte Arten des Genius aus der Welt der Musik bemüht. Und zwar gibt es einmal den klassischen Handwerker, der den ganzen Tag arbeitet, fleissig ist, seine Kunst perfektioniert, sehr bescheiden ist, der immer nur sagt, mir geht es nur um die Kunst, ich mache hier weiter und baue weiter meine Sachen und mache das und dann lasse ich mich auch nicht gross beklatschen, sondern mache gleich weiter. Beispiel wäre Bach. Klassischer Handwerker, sehr fleissig, protestantische Arbeitsethik, macht viel, macht weiter. Dann nämlich den zweiten, der von der Muse geküssten, dem, dem die Melodien zufliegen, der nur in den Kosmos hinaushorchen muss und der einfach nur die Melodien da niederschreiben muss, die ihm zufliegen. Ein Beispiel hier könnte sein Mozart. Mozart, du hast Wunderkind. Der dritte Typ. Das Wolfall. Auf Offa. Dritter Typ. Dritter Typ. Wäre der, der mit seiner Kunst ringt, der dem Material, das Genie abringen muss, der kämpft, der immer unzufrieden ist, der immer die Sachen wegwirft und sagt, ich bin unzufrieden und kämpft, der die Nächte durcharbeitet, der nicht zur Ruhe kommt, der immer das Letzte rausholt aus seiner Kunst und das wäre natürlich Beethoven. Beethoven. Okay, aber das ist jetzt ... Aber natürlich auch verschwimmen jetzt die Grenzen so ein bisschen, weil das Letzte ist auch quasi als Arbeitstier hinten raus ein bisschen verwässert. Aber es ist weniger der besonnene, bei klarem Verstand fleissig Arbeitende, sondern eher so der existenzielle Kämpfer, der ringt mit der Materie und der gegen sich selbst kämpft. Gegen sich selbst und gegen seine Ideen kämpft.
Der seine Kunst mit Blut schreibt.
Also ich finde nicht, dass du der erste Typ bist, einfach weil du zu faul bist.
Ich würde auch nicht sagen, dass du von der Muse geküsst jetzt hier sitzt, einfach weil du auch noch, glaube ich, dann noch ein bisschen dich zu sehr mit der Materie beschäftigst und dich dafür auch zu sehr interessierst, weil oft ist es ja auch so, dass solche Genies dann eigentlich über was anderes machen wollen, aber okay, sie können es halt und machen damit dann ihren Scheiß und machen nebenbei andere Dinge. Machst du nicht, du bleibst ja bei der Materie, bei Comedy. Deswegen würde ich eher zum dritten Teil rechnen. Also du siehst es mit Beethoven in mir.
Diesen Namen wollte ich bewusst umgehen.
Mit dem Podcastens oder der...
Ne, sagen wir mal, du bist der
Beethoven dieses Raumes.
Deiner Ecke des Raumes.
Bist du es unfair gerade jetzt
Cajons gegenüber?
Ja, das stimmt. Deswegen sage ich ja, du bist der Beethoven deiner Ecke des Raumes. Bist du unfair gerade jetzt Cajons gegenüber? Ja, das stimmt. Deswegen sage ich ja, du bist der Beethoven deiner Ecke des Raumes. Aber du bringst natürlich oft mit der Comedy-Materie und versuchst immer neue Facetten zu finden usw. Deswegen würde ich schon sagen. Aber du opferst dich dafür nicht auf. Also da kannst du noch ein bisschen mehr dich reinhängen. Falls ihr Stefan widerspricht, schreibt eine Postkarte an genie at gmail.org at geniusmail dot gph. Ja, nicht schlecht. Du denkst auch immer zwei Schritte weiter. Wir hatten ja gestern darüber gesprochen, der erste Impuls ist oft nicht der gute. Das heißt, der gute Komiker denkt immer schon direkt, der überspringt, der läuft so im Hopserlauf, der nimmt den nächsten Schritt vorweg, weil der immer schon über das Erwartbare hinüber hinwegsaust und schon … Brumpt, brumst. Brumpt? Brumst, neues Wort davon. Brumst. Das ist, wie genial ich bin. Das ist gar nicht schlecht. Brumst? Es ist ein bisschen an Brumft. Ich finde es auch immer schwierig, wenn Regisseure und Genies und Regisseure halt über ihre künstlerischen Tätigkeiten, Werke reden. Finde ich immer ganz schwierig. Deswegen fand ich Kubrick ja auch so geil. Es gibt auch keine Audiokommentare von ihm und so zu seinen vielen Blu-rays. Gibt es halt nicht, weil er das nie kommentiert hat, weil er es immer so für sich stehen lassen wollte. Das fand ich eigentlich ziemlich geil. Aber warum macht man sowas eigentlich, also diese Frage, die Hermeneutik, die Frage nach der Interpretation, was heißt das alles, was bedeutet das, warum macht man das eigentlich nur bei so Sachen wie Film und Musik, warum fragt man nicht mal so der Erfinder von Kinderriegeln, warum wird der nicht mal gefragt so, ja ja, das ist ja alles sehr lecker und bekömmlich, aber was haben sie sich denn dabei gedacht?
Wirklich so richtig als Kunst, das ist bei Kunst, das ist ein künstlerisches Ding und Kinderriegel werden nicht so als Kunst abgestempelt. Aber was ist der Unterschied jetzt zwischen Kinderriegel und Popmusik? Ich glaube die kreative Schaffungshöhe. Ich glaube, dass da auf so eine gewisse Art mehr Gedanken geflossen sind, Popsong jetzt nicht, aber in so einer klassischen Symphonie als in Kinderriegel, ehrlich gesagt. Es ist auch immer dieses E und U-Ding, also dieses Nutzen haben, um Leute wirklich zu ernähren, wie in Kinderriegel, oder Leute über ihr Leben hinaus Kultur zu bereichern. Meinst du, dass also der Kinderriegel primär durch die Akzeptanz des Käufers geformt ist und weniger durch den kreativen Geist des Schöpfers? Der probiert halt Sachen aus und guckt, was die Leute kaufen, wohingegen jetzt ein Film oder ein Kunstwerk primär dem kreativen Geist des Künstlers entspricht und nicht unbedingt dem Publikum. Das waren die schöneren Worte für das, was ich sagen wollte. Wir haben ja eine Ware gegenüber einem Kunstwerk.
Ja, das war jetzt wieder sehr platt. Wir waren eben schon weiter. Ich versuche es nochmal zu vereinfachen. Das hat der Deutsche ja genau so zu mir gesagt. Wir waren eben schon weiter. Ja, gut, Stefan, du hast gesagt, die E und U-Rechnung, was du nicht von unten bis vorne überhaupt gar keinen Sinn hast. Bei der E, es geht um Nutzen gegen Ertrag, also die E und U-Strategie. Wie wir am Anfang der Folge festgehalten haben, es ist nie die Abkürzung für das Anfangswort. R ist nicht gleich Reibung, U ist nicht, U ist gleich Nutzen. Nee, E und U ist ja die alte Diskussion, ist es Unterhaltung oder ist es ernst gemeint? Und dementsprechend... Wirklich? Das nennt man die E und U Diskussion? Ja. In welchem hermeneutischen Kontext? Ja! In welchem Diskurs, in welchem Diskurs, Stefan? Ich bringe die Diskussion mal auf eine neue Ebene, indem ich einfach rüber spreche. Okay, dann bringen wir die Diskussion... Das ist nicht tiefer. Ja, es ist schwer für mich. Ich versuche es schon wieder zu machen. Ey, was ist los, ich versuche... Aber dieses E und U könnt ihr selber nachlesen. Guck mal, irgendwie im Wikipedia-Artikel Kunst und so, dann könnt ihr E und U nachlesen, findet ihr unter den Buchstaben E und U. Du arbeitest ja auch gerade an deinem ersten Buch. Möchte ich jetzt nicht darauf eingehen. Und hast du auch vor, da die Buchstaben E und U zu benutzen? In welchem Kontext, in welcher Einfolge? Ja, und ich habe auch die Hoffnung, noch ein paar mehr Buchstaben unterzubekommen. Welche sollen sein? Ich habe aber ein bisschen Angst vor Umlauten. Ja. Wollte ich kurz nochmal drüber sprechen. Man weiss auch nicht immer, ob die dann dargestellt werden bei Computersprache. Das weiss man immer nicht so genau. Warum ist es eigentlich so, dass es bei Büchern oft nur dieselben Schriftarten gibt?
Dass man sich da nicht mal die Blödsinn gibt zu sagen, Schreibschrift oder Wingdings.
Mit Hand geschrieben, so ein handgeschriebenes Buch.
Manuskript, ja.
Rian Johnson, der neue Star-Wars-Regisseur, schreibt seine Drehbücher immer mit der Hand in diesen Notizbüchern. Das merkt man auch. Warum? Weil seine Filme noch so händisch. Ja, haben was Haptisches an sich, was Greifbares. Synonyme. Manchmal reichen Synonyme auch einfach, um Gespräch zu führen.
Es reicht doch einfach das, was der andere gesagt hat, einfach nochmal zu sagen mit anderen Worten.
Apropos Gespräch führen. Wir haben heute beide ein Video geguckt und da drin wurde aus dem Nichtspössischen der beste Tipp der Welt gegeben.
Und zwar, dass man, wenn man Smalltalk halten will, aber einem die Themen ausgehen und die Fragen ausgehen, sich einfach an dem ABC orientieren sollen. Und zwar die erste Frage, die dann nach dem A ist, die zweite nach dem B. Zum Beispiel, warst du schon mal in Aachen eigentlich? Wir können mal so ein Gespräch durchspielen. Tatsächlich, wir waren bei Cordula in Aachen und haben dort mit Cordula aufgenommen. Was ich mich aber tatsächlich frage, wie lange ist es her, dass du das letzte Mal die Bongo gespielt hast? Das ist eine sehr gute Frage. Ich spiele selten Bongos, weil ich
neuerdings immer am Computer sitze. Aha, und was machst du dann? Hast du da so ein eigenes Dosk oder was machst du da? Nee, das ist ganz interessant. Ich spiele halt meistens so ein paar Unterhaltungsspiele, aber auch ein paar ernstere Sachen. Aha, ernstere Sachen. Und dann Dann isst du dazu einfach ein Brot mit Focaccia, oder?
Nee, eigentlich genau das Gegenteil. Hund, Igel, Jacke, Kata-Doo. Aber tatsächlich ist das ein sehr guter Rat, den ich auch schon mal gehört habe in einem anderen Kontext. Und zwar habe ich mal gehört, ich weiss nicht, ob das stimmt oder ob man einfach generell versucht, jemanden zu pranken, und zwar habe ich gehört, ein Tipps auf die... Ein Problem, was sie durch dein Leben zieht. Auch in Schulbüchern immer, A-Quadratus-Bekalist, ja, das ist ja da schon ein grosser Zufall. Immer umguckt, ob die anderen die Formel auch zu lösen. War das ein Gag, den ich nicht verstanden habe? Sorry. Nehm jetzt bitte das Lineal. Also umgucken, ob die anderen das auch nehmen. Oder ob ich der Einzige bin. Wieder mal der Einzige. Und zwar tatsächlich habe ich gehört, dass wenn man in der Situation ist, eine Frau oral zu befriedigen und man nicht weiß genau, was man machen soll, dass man dann mit seiner Zunge das Alphabet nachformen soll. Das ist ja mega gut. Ich weiss nicht genau, was der Sinn dahinter ist, aber es ist wahrscheinlich eher dazu gedacht, dass man ein gewisses Selbstbewusstsein bekommt und überhaupt irgendwas macht und irgendwas Abwechslungsreiches macht vielleicht. Aber wie peinlich, wenn dir das auffällt und die sagen, I kommt nach H, nicht J. Oh, nicht die Umlaute jetzt auch. Du hast das J vergessen.
Und einfach so versucht, so Botschaften zu schreiben. Oh nein, ich hab einen Idioten im Bett. Genau, so Botschaften zu schreiben, so, nehmen ihn in den Mund, nehmen ihn in den Mund. Ist es gut so, ist es gut so, ist es gut? Unsicherheit. Fragezeichen, ja, Komma, was haben wir mit Komma-Regeln, alles in der Richtung, ne? Das mit Doppel-S? Ja, sowas in der Richtung. Das ist sehr lustig. Aber, also nur als guter Tipp da draußen, auch mal ein bisschen Stefans Fick-Tipps.
Hier ist einer der Ersten.
Ich glaube, das ist auch eine Rubrik, die wir nie weiterfinden.
Das ist einer der Ersten und Letzten.
Und Letzten höchstwahrscheinlich.
Was habe ich noch für Fick-Tipps?
Meistens mit, mach's mit Gummi, sondern...
Aber nicht nur mit Gummi, ne?
Das ist auch so ein Ding.
Man braucht schon noch einen Partner. Ja. Das ist dir wann aufgefallen? Tatsächlich erst vor kurzem. Das ist aber so ein bisschen Hauptsache Kondom. Der Rest ist erst mal zweiter, eigentlich tatsächlich. Haben wir das grosse Thema Kondome eigentlich schon mal abgearbeitet? Nee, da müssen wir jetzt echt mal ran eigentlich. Oder auch nicht eigentlich. Machen wir das Fenster erstmal auf.
Eigentlich nicht. Machen wir das Fenster auf. Oh, es ist ein bisschen warm geworden hier drin tatsächlich, ein bisschen zotig. Ja, und sonst so eigentlich? Ich kann ein bisschen Werbung machen tatsächlich. Ab 8. April läuft auf Rocket Beats TV verflixte Klicks mit Lars und mir die tolle Sendung, die ihr vielleicht auch kennt aus den alten Feedbunch-Zeiten. Und sehr interessant, wer ist in der zweiten Folge zu Gast bei dir? Äh, tatsächlich, Herbert Grönemeyer hat es geschafft, dort tatsächlich aufzuschlagen, was ein interessanter Fang für uns ist. Der wird kommen in der zweiten Folge, am 8. April geht es los. Aber er hat ja gesagt, dass er vielleicht nicht kann, er wackelt. Deswegen haben wir Udo Lindenberg noch als Plan B tatsächlich aufgeschaut. Vielen Dank für den Hinweis. Es könnte da auch Udo Lindenberg kommen. Und ihr könnt tatsächlich bei Verflickste Klicks selber mitspielen. Im Chat könnt ihr live mitspielen, wenn ihr das möchtet, könnt ihr das tun. Ab 8. April schaltet alle ein und für alle, die denken, ach bis 8. April, das dauert doch noch so lange, was mache ich denn bis dahin? Die Podcastfolgen habe ich alle schon hoch und runter gehört, deswegen habe ich noch eine kleine Podcastempfehlung für euch und zwar Last September in Monaco. Das ist ein toller neuer Podcast, den Stefan geschartet hat vor vier Wochen tatsächlich.
Vier Folgen sind schon draußen, ihr habt genug Hörfutter für die nächsten Runden Jogging im Park.
Könnt ihr euch das schon mal aufs Ohr legen? Ein tolles Podcast-Experiment mit den Changemen und Stefan Tietze.
Und Florian Will.
Und sag mal, wenn ich jetzt ein großer Star-Wars-Fan und...
Weiterhin gerne Antenna Alde ranhören.
Einer der besten deutschen star wars podcast
den machst du mit deinem kollegen und freund timo müller ihr seid zusammen jetzt fest und
wie ich habe ich habe zu gast gehabt ich habe ihm schon mehrmals das alphabet gezeigt dem
herrn timo und letztens hatten wir tatsächlich zu Gast, ähm, Cowell Quatsawick, der Synchronsprecher von diesem grossen Bären. Bernd das Brot. Diesem grossen Bären, ja, tatsächlich, und dem grossen Bären, der manchmal im Hintergrund zu sehen ist bei Star Wars. Ich weiß nicht, ob du das gesehen hast, aber manchen Shots im Hintergrund, so ein Monster, das so eine Prank hat, auch ganz gut. Bumper. Das ist Batman, das ist Superman gesehen, lass uns ganz kurz darüber reden, weil da ist auch so ein. War das die beste, gelangweilte Überladung der Welt, ey? Ich weiss jetzt schon, du willst eigentlich gar nicht darüber reden, aber die Leute waren ziemlich cool. Wir haben in letzter Folge über Nine Gags geredet, und auf Nine Gags entbricht gerade so ein bisschen so ein Streit von wegen, die Kritiker haben den gehatet, aber das Volk, die Zuschauer verteidigen ihn, fanden ihn gut und der Krieg entbrennt. Aber kurze Frage, haben ja über die Meinung Nein-Gags gesprochen, dass die meisten die Minderheitsmeinung einzunehmen. Die Minderheitsmeinung wäre doch eigentlich, den gut zu finden, also finden die Nein-Gag den gut? Nein. Hä? Es gibt ja eine Primärmeinung, die der Kritiker, die sagen, der Film ist schlecht. Und dann entsteht die Gegenbewegung, die sofort als die Independent, Undercover, wir gegen das Establishment-Meinung wahrgenommen wird.
Die finden ihn gut.
Die finden ihn gut und sagen dann so von wegen, lasst euch nicht von den Kritikern sagen, eure eigene Meinung selbstbestimmt.
Okay, aber Nein-Gag?
Und bitten dann die ganzen Ideologien an diese Meinung dann daran. Das ist mein Gag. So. Und dein Gag?
Aber ich will echt gerne wissen, was Nein-Gags Meinung jetzt ist.
Das ist die Nein-Gag-Meinung. So von wegen, lasst euch einen Krieg entnehmen.
Also wir meinen, die Minderheitsmeinung einzunehmen. Ja, genau. Aber die Minderheitsmeinung als Minderheitsmeinung. Ja, also ich fand den Film nicht gut, natürlich nicht, aber ich hab's auch nicht erwartet. Ich meine, ich fand keinen Sexneider-Film jemals gut, glaube ich. Echt, du fandest 300 nicht gut? Ne. Also die Action ist schön, immer anzugucken, gucke ich mir gerne an und das war auch dieses Mal wieder herrlich anzusehen, fotorealistische Supershots, hat mir gut gefallen, aber wer dann eine gute Story erwartet, die Story ist einfach, dann soll er einfach dann zu Hause sich vielleicht G-Z-E-S-T angucken und so, da gibt es tolle Stories, die sind packend, da spritzen die Figuren vor Lebensfreude und Unerwartbarkeit und dieses Mal war ich bei Se bei Zack Snyder dann natürlich nicht enttäuscht, weil ich dementsprechend nichts erwartet habe. Aber dann teilweise waren so Sachen, ich kann mal ein bisschen spoilern, Achtung, Sie hören jetzt einen Gong. Spoiler! Man sieht plötzlich dann irgendwann Aquaman und The Flash und so. Und quasi so eine Vorausschau auf die neuen, vorkommenden Filme.
Und das war schon ziemlich cool, dass man plötzlich so Cameos hat von geilen Superhelden, die dann auch noch undercover leben. Dann kommt Wonder Woman und der Soundtrack ist ganz okay, weil es Hans Zimmer ist, der macht immer ganz okaye Soundtracks, aber nie was Besonderes. Aber das waren ein paar Sachen, die gefallen dann doch ganz gut. Aber es ist interessant, dass er, obwohl er so schlecht rezipiert wurde, von fast allen eigentlich,
er trotzdem wahnsinnig viel Geld eingespielt hat, auch wirklich finanziell der grosse Erfolg war.
Glaubst du, wir kommen langsam in so ein Zeitalter, wo es auch schweckenweise egal ist, wie gut Filme sind,
weil Leute an dem Namen sich einfach schauen und dann kommt halt ein neuer Regisseur,
dann ist halt nicht mehr Zack Snyder, sondern jetzt kommt der J.J. Abrams, macht jetzt Batman,
all dem Order wird geil.
Ich glaube, Zack Snyder ist komplett egal. Ja, klar. Ich glaube, dass die meisten, die den Film gesehen haben, nicht mehr wissen, wer das ist. Ich glaube, das ist wirklich so ein Name. Batman-Movies waren in der letzten Zeit ganz okay. Die meisten, die hier rausgekommen sind, waren ganz gut anzugucken. Okay, er kämpft gegen den grössten Superhelden aller Zeiten. Superman muss gut werden. Ist auch so ein Familiending, glaube ich. Eltern schleppen da ihre Kinder mit rein, die noch keine eigenen Gedanken haben und sowas. Ich glaube schon. Aber auch hier wieder der gute Louis C. K. Gag. Was heißt Louis C. K.? Keine Ahnung. Jedenfalls, dass Leute, ja, also dass man mit, ich weiß nicht, wie teuer der Film war, mehrere hundert Millionen. Ja, zwei oder drei hundert Millionen sowas. Angenommen, die würden diese drei hundert Millionen Euro auf einen grossen H, die würden diese 300 Millionen Euro auf einen grossen Haufen legen, einfach das Geld auf einen grossen Haufen legen, würden Leute dafür bezahlen, diesen Haufen Geld zu sehen. Man kann ja auch anbieten, wenn du 10 Euro bezahlst, kannst du das sehen, wenn du 20 Euro bezahlst, kannst du dich mal reinlegen und sowas. Aber du bräuchtest den Film nicht, du bräuchtest diesen unangenehmen Mittelweg nicht. Ich würde tatsächlich 10 Euro zahlen, um einen Berg von drei Millionen Euro zu sehen. Auf jeden Fall. Und es würden mehr Leute das machen als Superman und Spider-Man. Ja, vor allem man kann das Geld, das man zahlt, ja dann alle wieder auf den Berg legen und dann ist der Berg grösser und nächstes Jahr kann man ihn sich nochmal anschauen. Aber das würde ich sagen, das kostet 15 Dollar. Dass man sein Geld drauflegen kann. Dass man sein Geld drauflegen kann. Das kostet noch mehr. Oder die 5 Euro, die man mehr bezahlt, dann drauflegen.
Alles über 10 Euro darf man auf dem Berg legen.
Darf man drauflegen.
Und dann kann man nächstes Jahr sich den Berg wieder anschauen, weil er ein bisschen grösser geworden ist.
Ja, fände ich mega cool.
Das ist ideal.
Du würdest auch die Inflation beenden, weil wenn das Geld da liegt, können Zauberer nicht mehr zerreissen.
Und dadurch entsteht ja bekanntlich die Inflation.
Zauberer zerreissen Geld.
Aber zerreissen ist wirklich. Oder ist das nur ein Zaubertrick?
Wenn die einen Vogel vermeintlich verschwinden lassen und dann ein anderer entscheidet, ist es meistens ein anderer Vogel. Der erste ist tot.
Aber denkt der Vogel, er sei der Alte? Oder weiss er das?
Oder wurde der Vogel nur geklont?
Glaubst du, Zauberervögel sind unter Vögeln sehr uncool oder sehr cool? Es kam zu oft das Wort Vögel in diesem Satz vor. Dann machen wir Kaninchen, dann machen wir Kaninchen. Die Kaninchen aus dem Hut. Ja. Ist es ein beliebtes Kaninchen unter den Kaninchen oder sagst du eher doch Gott, er wieder. Ja, die kennen den ja nicht. Die zaubert den ja aus dem Nichts. So, und dann müssen die den ja erstmal kennenlernen. Hey, kommst du? Ja, ich bin Jeff, ich komme aus dem Hut. Na, ging es dir da gut? Ja, und ich muss sagen, mir fehlt dir der Mut. Es redet ja nur in Reimen, was echt unangenehm ist. Aber sonst glaube ich, ist es relativ beliebt, ja. Wir waren bei G, glaube ich. Wir waren bei Mark K, waren wir, glaube ich, wirklich. Es ist perfekt. Lass uns das mal unterbewusst im nächsten dieser Podcasts machen. Dieser Podcast-Reihe. Wir haben ja oft manchmal Pausen, die wir rausschneiden, wo wir uns eine Stunde lang anschweigen, weil wir den Hass nicht mehr ertragen können oder die Liebe und wenn wir einfach den nicht... Ist ganz so gemütlich hier. Aber um Stephans Körperhaltung zu beschreiben, er hat klassisch diese, ich bekomme gerade einen Blowjob Körperpose.
Er hat so die linke Hand hinter dem Hinterkopf und streckt den linken Ellenbogen hoch in die Luft, ganz gross, Hüfte weit raus, Beine breit, sitzt er da gerade auf seinem Stuhl und dieses verschmitzte Lächeln, die Augen so zu kaum erkennbaren Schlitzen gekniffen, sitzt er da und lässt es sich einfach gut gehen. Da sind wir wieder. Herzlich willkommen zu Kylie Minogue mit ihrem neuen Hip, Can't Live Without You. Mit ihrem neuen Hip, Back to the Hits. Zurück zu Stefan Tetzel. Wir wurden ihm unterbrochen, weil du angerufen wurdest von Udo Lindenberg, er hat auch abgesagt. Tatsächlich. Für eure zweite Folge. Wer ist jetzt euer Gast? Glücklicherweise haben wir noch Anne Will in der Hinterhand, Plan C. Und deswegen schaut alle mal rein am 8.4. Verflicksilicks. Rockbeans TV, twitch.com, slash Rockbeans TV. Wo siehst du dich genau in fünf Jahren? In einem Spiegel. Mein Gott, Stefan, was soll ich machen? Ich habe keine Pointen mehr übrig. Ich weiß nicht, was Sie sagen. Mein Köcher ist voller dummer Fragen. Ich kann so weitermachen. Meine Perspektive sieht tatsächlich relativ düster aus. Ich nehme momentan wieder zu. Das heißt, wenn ich so weitermache, wie ich momentan zunehme, bin ich in fünf Jahren ich 700 Kilo. Ich finde das total lustig. Ich habe noch nie jemandem sowas sagen hören und wusste dabei in meinem Kopf die Antwort, weil das Problem so einfach zu lösen ist. Du bestellst dir seit Wochen, jede Woche ein Paket von World of Sweets. Ja, ich weiss. Wenn du das Problem vor dir siehst, okay, ich werde immer dicker, vielleicht solltest du da anfangen, ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher. Aber das ist dieser Internet-Shopping-Sumpf, man fängt an und man klickt rum und man denkt, oh geil, oh das noch, jetzt bestelle ich sowieso und klick dann einfach noch ein bisschen rum. Es kam heute zwei Pakete an von World of Sweets. Ich verstehe das nicht, also es ist ein sehr einfach zu lösen das Problem. So gut, meine Jugend wurde ruiniert durch World of Warcraft und jetzt meine anfangs erwachsene Zeit wird ruiniert durch World of Sweets. Wurde ich mit deiner Seniorenzeit ruiniert? Ich bin sehr gespannt, tatsächlich. World of After Eight. Ja, das war jetzt auch schon die Phase. World of After Eight. Das ist eine gute Website. Das erste Assoziation, die ich mit alten Leuten habe, ist After Eight. Nee, fünf Jahre, ich gucke nicht so weit in die Zukunft. Ich schaue mal, was auf mich zukommt jetzt die nächsten Wochen. dann gucke ich mal, ob ich bald in den Urlaub fahre. Tatsächlich Ende des Monats fliegen wir beide ja nach Amerika. Eijau, dann machen wir eine tolle Hollywood-Folge. Ja, tatsächlich. Eine Hollywood-Folge aus New York. Ich weiß nicht, ob wir unsere Spitzenzungen überhaupt ins Flugzeug bekommen oder ob die nicht sagen, ihr seid zu scharf, ihr habt die heissen Gäste. Wir fliegen sogar, wir stehen auf der gleichen Buchungskarte von Lufthansa. Wie Matt Damon. Und direkt hintereinander, weil T und W ja sehr nah beieinander liegen. Und wir alleine reisen. Wie wir eben gelernt haben beim Alphabet, Leute. Deswegen kann es sein, dass wir nebeneinander sitzen im A380, wo ich mich sehr darauf freue, weil es das grösste Passageflugzeug der Welt ist. Und wir fliegen zusammen nach New York nebeneinander, acht Stunden verbringen wir nebeneinander.
The Big Apple.
Isst du auf dem Flug immer einen grossen Apfel?
Ich glaube, ich werde einen Apfel, ich glaube, ich werde, sobald ich in New York ankomme, werde ich einen Apfel holen und ein Foto machen und sagen, der ist gar nicht so gross.
Ist vielleicht, ist jetzt ein Gag.
Die sind ja gar nicht so gross.
Sowas, ja. Oder dann irgendwie die Erwartungen, was man erwartet hat. Hier ist ja gar nicht Woody Allen und schaut aus dem Fenster. Sowas. In der Art. New York, New York. New York, I love you. New York. Ja, interessant. Sehr interessant. Sehr, sehr interessant alles. Muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Was habe ich hier noch? Und zwar folgendes. Es gibt eine Maschine, die wurde gebaut, um herauszufinden, was der lustigste Witz der Welt ist. Das ist kein Scheiss. Wie sieht diese Maschine aus? Ich stelle mir gerade einen riesigen grauen Kasten mit ganz vielen leuchtenden Lampen und Hebeln vor. Mit einem grossen Smiley in der Mitte. Genau, ja. Und so eine Blume, wo Wasser rauskommt. Ja.
Ha, ha, ha. Und dieser Kasten hat herausgefunden, dass einfach nur ein Wirrwarr, es muss möglichst absurd sein. Also für den hat herausgefunden, der Kasten, dass es möglichst absurd sein muss. Und dann auf die Frage irgendwie, was ist zweimal zwei, hat der irgendwie einfach so ein Nonsenswort entwickelt, so irgendwie so ein Sombolumbiba, einfach irgendwas, was möglichst absurd ist und hat herausgefunden, dass es am lustigsten ist. Für ihn, also es ist ja subjektiv Humor, deswegen, also ich finde es am lustigsten. Seit Tagen sitzt er dann da und sagt, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, hoffel, hoffel, hoffel, hoffel, hoffel, hoffel, ich kann nicht mehr, töte mich, töte mich, ich hab, zieh den Stecker. Ja, aber ganz interessant für uns jetzt, weil ich merke, dass die Wissenschaft sich in ein Gefilde bewegt, wo ich ein bisschen Angst habe, meinen Job zu verlieren. Das stimmt, sobald die Gagmaschine... Aber es ist interessant, es gibt verschiedene Absurditätslevel, weil du könntest jetzt sagen, es ist eine gute Feedline, zwei plus zwei. Ich würde jetzt sowas sagen wie Fisch. So, da kannst du halt sagen, okay, das ist schon absurd, aber was ist noch absurder? Weil wir haben die Zahlen verlassen und wir haben schon potenzielle andere Antworten verlassen und sind jetzt schon bei Lebewesen, die da überhaupt nicht sein könnten. Gibt es noch etwas Absurderes als Fische oder ist ab dann man schon entfernt? Stell dir mal die Frage. Zwei plus zwei ist? Die Zahl... Nochmal? Was ist zwei plus zwei? Die Antwort auf die Frage, wie oft ich deine Mutter gevögelt habe. Bäm! Kommt schon. Ja. Ja, ist okay, aber es... Abgestop aber ist ja. Abgestumpft. Abgestumpft. Humor prallt an ihm ab. Er hat seine schutzsichere Weste an, seine schutzsichere Humorweste wieder an. Bis zu welchen Buchstaben bist du gekommen bei ihr? Z. Aber genau Z. Genau bis Z. Ansonsten fängt man wieder von vorne an oder ist dann einfach Schluss? Ne, ich mache dann bei Sonderzeichen weiter. Scharfes S.
Sternchen, geschweifelt Klammer auf, geschweifelt Klammer zu.
Raute, hätte ich jetzt gesagt, ja.
Raute, ja.
Strich oben nach links richtet, a son tégue, a son to grave, a circumflex.
Ui, holala, bonjour, bitte regissene meine die Vizephiken.
Was war das für die Stelle in Folge 53, wo ihr angefangen habt, auf Französisch zu sprechen? Wie stellst du dir den Podcast-UFO-Hörer vor? Nimm jetzt mal die Rolle des Podcast-UFO-Hörers ein. Oh, hallo Klaus, was hörst du denn da? Es ist zufällig ein Podcast entdeckt hier. Aha. Und worum geht es da? Ja, wie zum zwei Männern, Aber ich habe jetzt auch gar nichts reingehört. Ich wollte es wieder ausmachen eigentlich. Können wir zusammen jetzt ja weitermachen am Bau. Wir arbeiten ja am Bau. Ich habe schon zwei Bierchen gehört. Ich weiss, dass wir auf dem Bau arbeiten, musst du nicht sagen. Was ich mit diesem kleinen Scherzchen jetzt bezwecken wollte, ist, ich wollte aussagen, dass ich glaube, die meisten hören es aus Versehen. Ach so. Du meinst, die aus Versehenen sich Sachen geklaut haben und dann von... Nein, die aus Versehenen auf unseren Titel gekommen sind. Auf unsere... Ich glaube, die meisten denken ja immer noch, dass wir über Ausserirdische sprechen die meiste Zeit. Du arbeitest ja gerade in einem Buch über Ausserirdische. Erzähl doch mal mehr von deinem Buch. Nein, ich glaube einfach... Das ist wie so ein Promogespräch. Du versuchst immer wieder auf dein Scheissbuch zu lenken. Es ist doch nicht mehr geschrieben. Du hast heute geredet über das Alphabet, ja, während du ein Buch schreibst, über Ausserirdische. Und jetzt sagst du, die Leute wollen das über Ausserirdische reden. Wenn du über dein Buch sprechen willst, dann sprechen wir über dein Buch. Viel lieber als bei meinem Buch, was am 21. April 2016 erscheint, würde ich gerne mit dir nochmal zurückkommen auf folgendes. Also, ich finde, du willst oft sehr alternativ leben. Und deswegen hast du World of Sweets entdeckt. Jetzt sehe ich hinter mir, hinter dir, Chips, die ich noch nie im Laden gesehen habe. Und ich frage mich echt, manchmal habe ich so ein Gefühl. Und zwar, warum reichen dir die Dinge, die es bei uns im Laden zu kaufen gibt, nicht mehr aus? Du, ich bin Grenzgänger. Mein Leben ist das Limit. Ich lebe am Limit, mein Leben ist der Hauptzahm. Ja, das hast du auch schon in der Bewerbung geschrieben, mit der du dich bei der BTF beworben hast. Ja, genau. Aber jetzt würde ich gerne wissen, warum reichen dir auch als Grenzgänger nicht die normalen Süßigkeiten? Weil ich einfach Gründe brauche, um noch mehr Sachen in mich hineinzustopfen. Wenn ich mir denke, ich kaufe mir die gleichen Chips wie immer, denke ich mir, nee, du fette Schwein, hör auf zu fressen. Aber so denke ich mir, die sind ja neu und die muss ich ja ausprobieren. Ja, ist es das? Und dann bestelle ich mir die und denke mir, ich bin ja so ein Chips-Konnisseur und ich kenne mich ja aus, bla bla bla und das ist eigentlich alles nur, das ist eigentlich nur eine Ausrede, um noch mehr Sachen zu kaufen, die ich eigentlich sonst gar nicht essen würde. Das ist auch lustig, die Vorstellung daran, da, da, da, davon, deswegen, dass Leute, weil es gibt ja so, so, so, Weinverkostungen und sowas und Käseverkostungen, wenn man das mit etwas macht, was nicht so schwierig ist herzustellen und ob es einfach gleich schmeckt, Milch oder, da weiss ich nicht, ob das, ich glaube, da hast du dich jetzt in ganz dicke Brennungslösung Avocados ich glaube, wenn dann sowas industriell hergestellt ist wie Kinderriegel ein Kinderriegel-Konnoisseur ist, glaube ich, relativ überflüssig sorry an die Hörer, die jetzt versuchen, diesen Job zu ergreifen momentan ich glaube, für alle da draußen die noch nicht wissen, was sie beruflich machen wollen. Wir haben ja viele Hörer im Studentenalter und im Schuleralter, wo glaube ich viele sich noch denken, was soll ich machen, viele Dinge, die ich so sehe, interessieren mich nicht. Deswegen einfach den Tipp, wenn ihr keinen Job findet, der euch gefällt, erfindet einfach einen neuen Job und seid einfach der Erste in dem Job, weil niemand kann euch sagen, dass ihr schlecht in diesem Job seid, weil es keine Referenz gibt, genauso wie ein neues Studienfach. Irgendwann hat ja mal jemand angefangen, irgendwie so Gender Studies oder sowas anzufangen, die es vorher nicht gab, und welche, bei wem musste derjenige eine Prüfung ablegen, der dieses Studienfach erfunden hat? Doch niemand. Wer war der Mensch, der zum ersten Mal Gender Studies studiert hat? Ja, genau. Eine gute Frage. Und irgendjemand muss gesagt haben, ne, ich mach das jetzt, ich schreibe jetzt die Prüfungen für Gender Studies und es gibt über mir keine Kompetenz mehr, zack, bumm. Das heißt, ihr könnt einfach neue Berufsherrscher und einfach Kinderregelkonnoisseur werden und niemand kann sagen, ne, das seid ihr gar nicht, weil ihr seid die höchste mögliche Kompetenz, die es gibt zu dem Thema. Habe ich mich auch schon mal gefragt, wenn man in 100 Jahren Mathematik studiert, weiss man ja wesentlich mehr über Mathematik als vor 100 Jahren. In dem Sinne, dass es mehr herausgefunden wurde und so, auch Physik. Dauert das dann nicht länger, zu studieren? Ja, und kann man nicht irgendwann nicht mehr alles nachholen, um neue Erkenntnisse zu erreichen? Ich glaube, deswegen hat sie irgendwann angefangen, die Studienfächer zu spitalisieren. Deswegen gibt es dann halt jetzt Medien- und Kommunikationswissenschaft, Schwerpunkt, Chips. Die Frage ist ja auch, ob nicht das Wissen irgendwann wieder kleiner wird. Weil irgendwann, du hast ja in der Physik zum Beispiel wahnsinnig viele Formeln, aber vielleicht findest du ja irgendwann die Formel, die alle anderen Formeln integriert. Und dann kannst du alle wieder streichen, du kannst alle Bücher wegschmeissen und hast nur noch Formel E ist gleich B hoch zwei. Ich würde kurz mal, wir haben eben über deinen Genie gesprochen, ich würde gerne über meinen Genie sprechen. Bitte. Ich habe nämlich Folgendes herausgefunden, ich dachte mir, ich habe so eine Phase gehabt, wo ich mir sehr viel angelesen habe über Astronomie und so, Und da bin folgendes ausgedacht, es gibt ja sowas wie eine Lichtgeschwindigkeit, ist ja die naturgegebene Geschwindigkeit für Licht, ist eine Konstante, Naturkonstanten gibt es ja auch, genau wie Pi, und sowas wie der Meter ist ja quasi nicht genullt, das ist menschengemacht. So, wenn man alles das, wenn man quasi Lichtgeschwindigkeit als Geschwindigkeitsmass, quasi die Sekunde, die wir haben, verändert, so, dass es ein kleinerer Vielfache von der Lichtgeschwindigkeit ist zum Beispiel. Das ist quasi alles, dass man sich an die Natur angleicht, guckt, wie die Naturkonstanten zusammenhängen, und dann sich eine eigene Welt der Formeln und der Gesetzmäßigkeiten baut. So ist es ja. Das ist sein eigenes Metrum. Nein, das ist nicht. Also Kilo passt nicht zu Sekunde, das ist alles anders, weil man irgendwann mal ein Beispiel Kilo genommen hat, man hat irgendwann mal ein Beispiel Meter genommen, man hat irgendwann mal eine Beispiel Sekunde, alles sind menschengemachte Einheiten. Doch, aber Meter passt zu Kilo. Gut, Meter passt zu Kilo, weiß ich nicht. Zum Beispiel. Aber du hast ja Quadrat, Kubikdezimeter, Wasser ist ein Kilo. Okay, aber wenn du sowas wie Masse ausrechnen willst oder auch die Geschwindigkeit brauchst, für Geschwindigkeit brauchst du auch die Zeit, das ist ja alles menschengemacht. Aber Lichtgeschwindigkeit ist halt von der Natur vorgegeben, wenn man das halt so klein macht, dass es auf eine Sekunde passt und quasi so unsere Zeit dann neu rechnet. Und das gab es schon alles. Genau diese Gedanken hat sich auch jemand gemacht, das heißt nämlich die Planck-Welt. Max Planck hat dafür sogar einen Nobelpreis bekommen. Für die Idee, die du auch gestern Abend in der Badewanne hattest. Er wusste natürlich wesentlich mehr, vorher schon, und hat wesentlich mehr daraus dann gemacht und hat dann auch Zusammenhänge zwischen denen erzählt und hat dann versucht, dementsprechend alles zu nullen auf die Naturkonstanten. Und das nennt man, glaube ich, die Plankeinheiten. Ganz interessant. Dann habe ich mir wiederum überlegt, bin ich nur auf die Idee gekommen, weil die Wissenschaftler, von denen ich mir Videos angeguckt habe, davon wussten, dementsprechend alles so erzählt haben, dass ich irgendwie in diese Richtung gelenkt wurde. Es hat noch kein Wissenschaftler in einem Video von den Planck-Einheiten erzählt. Ja, aber du lebst ja nach Planck. Das heisst, du lebst ja in einer Welt, die Planck bereits mitgeformt hat. Richtig genau. Das heisst, du hast es ja schon mitgelernt und dadurch ist es für dich selbstverständlich, dass die Dinge so funktionieren. Sagt man auch über Einstein, dass er gar nicht so ein Genie war, sondern der Zeitgeist. Es war nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis jemand darauf kommt, so das sagen viele Leute. Weil es ist ja gerade viel, das Feld der Physik hat sich darüber gerade viele Gedanken gemacht zu der Zeit und es war nur eine Frage der Zeit, bis jemand damit kommt und hier kommt. Es gibt ja auch so die Frage zum Beispiel die Griechen, ob die dachten, die Erde ist eine Scheibe oder eine Kugel. Und man denkt ja sofort, ja, die waren alle total dumm und dachten, alle ist eine Scheibe, aber es ist tatsächlich so, dass auch viele antike Wissenschaftler und Gelehrte auch davon ausgegangen sind, dass es eine Kugel ist, obwohl die ja überhaupt gar nicht verstehen konnten, was jetzt Schwerkraft ist und wie das alles funktioniert und andere Planeten und alles in der Richtung. Ich meine, natürlich, du kannst den Mond sehen und siehst, okay, der ist kreisförmig. Ob das jetzt eine Scheibe ist, komisch, weil wir sehen sie nie so von der Seite, deswegen Kugel, also könnten wir sagen, die Erde ist auch einfach eine Kugel. Dreht sich nicht. Aber sie können einfach, okay, gut. Gebundene Rotation. Ja, du hast die gebundene Rotation auf deinen Blick gearmt. Dreht sich einmal, während er sich um die Erde dreht, um sich selber. Ist das nicht auch ein Riesenzufall? Oder ist das auch irgendwie synchronisiert worden? Nee, das ist kein Zufall, das ist gebundene Rotation. Wie ist das denn? Hat sich angeglichen an die Erdumdrehung. Warum? Warum, weiß ich doch nicht. Das ist unwichtig. Ja, aber die Erde hat sich ja auch nicht an die Sonne angeglichen. Nee, aber die Erde hat einen wesentlich geringeren Einfluss auf die Sonne als der Mond auf die Erde. Ja, aber als die, ja, eben. Der Mond ist relativ gross für den Mond. Du sagst, der Mond hat einen grösseren Einfluss auf die Erde als die Erde auf die Sonne. Auf jeden Fall, ja. Habe ich das nicht gesagt? Doch, hast du gesagt, aber ich möchte nur nochmal klarstellen. Ja, weil die Erde, der Mond ist zur Erde sehr verhältnismäßig gross. Aber ist es nicht so, der Mond ist, Russland ist grösser als der Mond? Nee, Pluto war das, glaube ich. Der Hund. Also Pluto ist, nein, Russland ist die Max-Sank-Konstante für, Russland ist kein Planet mehr. Ein Coulomb pro Sekunde mal Pluto ist grösser als Russland. Letztlich. Gleich R. B, C, D. Ich finde das so interessant. Neben uns wird gerade ein Trenner für eine andere Sendung geschnitten. Trenner heisst, wenn halt ein Spiel angesagt wird und so. Und die ist eine wahnsinnig grosse Sendung, die wir alle irgendwann mal bestimmt sehen in ihrer Zukunft. Die ist nicht zu übersehen, die ist so riesengroß, die könnt ihr gar nicht übersehen. Die nimmt Sender ein, ganze Sender ein. So, und wir sehen gerade, wie ein Trenner dafür geschnitten wird nebenan. Und kannst du das aber kurz, kurz, kurz drüber? Und ich, lass uns mal raten, was das für ein Spiel sein wird. Gut, das ist natürlich für den Zuschauer überhaupt gar nicht erschliefbar. Deswegen sollen wir das natürlich erklären. Okay, also wir sehen eine holzerne Wand oder so eine Art. Eine holzerne Wand? Er sucht sich gerade eine Musik raus tatsächlich für diesen Trenner. Verschiedene Dien raus. Ich glaube, du hast ja ein sehr schlechtes Timing gerät. Ich habe einen sehr schlechten, massiv schlechten Zeitpunkt gelegt zeitpunkt weil er jetzt gerade aufhört an dem tatsächlichen design zu arbeiten jetzt steht er auf jup oh okay vielleicht mal ganz kurz einfach noch mal wir kommen darauf zurück wir kommen darauf zurück tatsächlich drauf zurück sorry du hast da wasabi-nüsse stehen w Wissenschaft. Ja, die habe ich mir auch bei World of Sweets bestellt.
Aber kannst du die bitte aufmachen?
Okay.
Da musst du jetzt kurz überbrücken. 30 Sekunden. Ab jetzt.
So, ich darf jetzt endlich mal, eigentlich endlich mal habe ich Zeit für mich und für meine Gags.
Ich werde nicht von Florentin unterjocht, sondern kann mein eigenes Ding hier durchziehen.
Und ich fühle mich jetzt ein bisschen frei gerade, weil ich habe nicht die Angst, dass irgendwer mal gleich kommt und das unterbricht, sondern einfach mal meinen Gedanken feinen Lauf lässt. Und so könnte es sein, wenn ich allein diesen Podcast moderiere, er hätte einen freien Stefan mit okayen Gags. Es wäre nicht so lustig, glaube ich. Es wäre ein ernsterer Podcast. Ich würde viel über meine eigenen Probleme erzählen. 30 Sekunden sind, glaube ich, noch nicht rum. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange 30 Sekunden sind. Wir haben moderieren gelernt hier an der Uni. Und da haben wir gelernt ... Was hast du für eine Note im Moderieren bekommen? 99 Punkte, eine Eins plus. Von 8000. Und da haben wir gelernt, dass 30 Sekunden länger oder kürzer sind, als man denkt. Weiß ich nicht mehr. Je nachdem, wer man ist. Ciao! Da hast du nur 99 Punkte bekommen bei dieser Erkenntnis. Was war der letzte Punkt? Ich würde gerne deinen Dozenten fragen oder Dozentin, was ist der letzte Punkt, der Stefan gefehlt hat für die 100? Oh yeah. Aber ärgert dich das nicht, 99 Punkte zu bekommen? Da ist doch die erste Frage, ja warum nicht 100, oder? Ich glaube so ein bisschen, da fragt dann die Uni auch den Dozenten nach. Was war da 100 Punkte? Kann das wirklich sein? Stefan, ah, okay. Entschuldigung, dass wir gefragt haben, es geht alles in Ordnung. Geben sie mir 120. Danke. Das sind genau die, die Bastian Pastewka in der Serie Pastewka ist. Wie heisst die noch gleich? Wie heisst die noch mal in der Serie? Sag schnell. Bastian Pastewka in... Sag schnell. Wie heisst die noch mal? Huecker heisst die noch mal? Schmitz? Balder, Balder. Balder, nee. Kibikus, ach fuck, jetzt weiss ich nicht mehr. Aber ich glaube, da sind Erdnüsse bei Pastewka. Was sind das denn da drin? Erbsen. What?
Das sind Erbsen?
Ja.
Ist das gesünder oder ungesünder als Erdnüsse?
Wesünder. Wesünder.
Also was heißt Gesundheit? Weniger Fett. Nüsse haben nicht viel Fett.
Und Wasabi an sich?
Wasabi Senf. Ich glaube, der ist vernachlässigbar an Nährwärten.
Senf, ne?
Ja, sowas wie Meerrettich halt.
Ist Meerrettich ein Senf?
Es gibt ja zwei Arten von Schärfe tatsächlich. Z komplett und es gibt diesen Schärfegrad, Scoville,
aber damit kann man nur die Schärfe von Chilis messen und die Schärfe von so Wurzelgewächsen wie Senf und Meerrettich und sowas
haben eine ganz andere Art von Schärfe, die man nicht mit diesem, vielleicht stimmt es auch nicht,
aber es gibt auf jeden Fall zwei Arten von Schärfe, die Chilischärfe und die Senfschärfe. Und die Heisenbergsche Schärfe, Unschärfe. Die gibt es auch noch, wollte ich noch mal kurz sagen. Man kennt ja Wasabien so, geht ja primär durch die Nase, die Schärfe, und bei Chili ist es eher dann so Zungenachenraum. Sehr, sehr gut. Da haben wir wieder den ersten Tize an Land gezogen. Der zappelt dann noch. Der erste? Das war der erste echte Tize der Folge, würde ich sagen. So typisch. Ich bin ja Tize-Konnoisseur. Ich kann ja jedem den richtigen Tize. B du auch Tietze-Fan eigentlich? Ne, ich kenne mich nur sehr gut aus. Ich brauche die Distanz für meinen Job. Wenn Leute zu mir kommen und sagen, ich bräuchte mal so ein Tietze irgendwie abends, kurz vorm Einschlafen, noch mal kurz auf den Mond, ins Sternenhimmel schauen, welchen Tietze kannst du mir empfehlen, sage ich Folge 26, Minute 18 und 13 Sekunden. Das ist der perfekte Titel für den Moment. Cool. Naja, Serien, kannst du Serien empfehlen? Falls die Zuschauer sich denken, warum zur Hölle höre ich mir den Schwachsinn gerade an, warum schaue ich mir nicht Serie? Love. Love von Judd Apatow, die neue Serie mit Gillian Jacobs, die man vielleicht schon aus Community kennt, jetzt die neue Netflix-Serie Love.
Ja, die gefällt mir gut, die Figuren gefallen mir gut, die Gags gefallen mir gut, die Musik gefällt mir gut, die Scrading. Ich habe selten so gelacht beim Grading. Catering war sehr gut. Ich habe oft gedacht, wow, also bei den besten Comedyfilmen fehlt mir manchmal Serien, fehlt mir manchmal so ein bisschen noch, dass es das Grading mitspielt, die Gags untermauert. Ich glaube, die Leute, das ist nicht nur was Grading ist, das ist die Farbkultur. Darauf will ich auch umreiten. Ach so, okay, sorry. Nicht so schlimm. Naja, die Fahrer waren gut und weitere Berufe, die man eigentlich gar nicht oft in tatsächlichen Werk sehen kann. Naja, also, ich schaue gerade The Last Kingdom, ist eine Mittelalter-Serie. Moonrise Kingdom, sehr zu empfehlen. Auch acht Jahre alt oder so. Aber gut. Naja. Mein Vorteil ist, dadurch dass ich immer, ich habe jetzt Per Anhalter durch die Galaxis entdeckt, also den Film kann ich natürlich schon, aber das Buch lese ich jetzt zum ersten Mal. Ganz kurz, ganz kurz. Wirklich, die letzte Woche labert mir Stefan jeden Tag die Ohren ab. Per Anhalte durch die Galaxis ist ein Buch, das achtzehn Jahre alt ist, wo du mir denkst, das hast du jetzt entdeckt. Ja, aber der grosse Vorteil daran ist, ich kenne das Buch ja auch schon und ich kenne auch den Film, ich wollte es nur noch mal lesen. Und der grosse Vorteil daran ist, dass du halt Gags daraus einfach rezitieren kannst im Alltag und alle denken, das wären deine, weil alle mittlerweile schon vergessen haben, dass es diesen Gag überhaupt gibt. Nein, ganz im Gegenteil, die Leute wissen ganz genau. Und ich sage, ha, lustig, ich habe immer ein Handtuch dabei, weil das Handtuch hilft mir, dann denken alle, wow, sehr genial, mega gut. Das ist nur lustig, weil man veranhaltlich die Galaxis kennt. Ach so, deswegen lachen alle über mich. Du dachtest, die Leute lachen, weil die sich direkt... Weil ich einen Bademann ertrage die ganze Zeit. Und nichts drunter. Ja, deswegen dachte ich, weil ich einen zweiten Kopf plötzlich habe und drei Arme. Da dachte ich, lachen die Leute jetzt über mich. Du meinst, die lachen nur über mich, weil die den Film geschehen haben schon. Was ist dein Lieblings-Science-Fiction-Universum außer Star Wars? Hm, per andere durch die Galaxis. Sage ich jetzt gerade, weil ich mich damit beschäftige. Außer per andere durch die Galaxis. Rick and Morty. Man in Black? Nee. Ja, gefällt dir nicht? Ein bisschen zu trashig, aber das Universum ist uns cool, ja. Schwierig, gute Frage. Hm, ist die Frage, ob Superman und so dazugehören. Ne. Ich würde Superhelden als eigene Genre. Was ist dein Lieblings-Superhelden-Universum? Lieblings-Superhelden-Universum? Marvel oder DC? Was ich auch so geil finde, dass es da so zwei grosse, rivalisierende Unternehmen gibt, die ihre beiden Superhelden haben und die nicht nur gegeneinander innerhalb kämpfen, sondern eigentlich ja auch so ein bisschen ihre Superhelden gegeneinander, ihre Superheldenarmeen aufeinander laufen lassen. Aber ganz kurz, wer würde gewinnen? Naval oder DC? Ich glaube, mit der Frage können wir nur falsch liegen. Aber ich meine, wir sind ja momentan in der zweiten Phase oder vielleicht in der dritten Phase der Superheldenfilme. Superheldenfilme haben ganz harmlos angefangen und dann wurden sie immer populärer und dominieren mittlerweile den gesamten Filmmarkt. Und mittlerweile kommen schon Crossovers, Avengers, wir sehen mehrere Superhelden, jetzt behalten wir als Superman, Superhelden kämpfen gegeneinander. Und das wird sich ja immer weiter aufbauen und aufbauen. Wohin soll es noch gehen? Irgendwann wird es ja den Megafilm Marvel vs. DC geben. Oder irgendwann, weil die sind ja auch nicht dumm. Die wissen ja genau, klar, die einen bauen ihre Leute auf, die anderen bauen ihre Leute auf. Nur um dann in drei Jahren, wenn die Marktanalysten sagen, Leute, wirklich, wir haben jetzt nur noch 20 Minuten für diesen scheiss Superhelden-Hype, jetzt kommt noch mal alles raushauen, dann kommt der grosse Marvel vs. DC-Film, Filmreihe und dann geht noch mal alles kaputt und dann haben wir es hoffentlich auch endlich hinter uns, weil ich habe das Interesse an Superhelden schon vor Jahren verloren. Womit? Nach Dark Knight war für mich eigentlich aus. Der erste Iron Man war cool, Dark Knight war cool, der erste Avengers war cool und ich fand, mit dem ersten Amazing Spider-Man hat es für mich dann schon aufgehört. Amazing Spider-Man 2 war noch immer ganz gut, wäre besser als die. Spider, Tommy McQuire ist für mich auch ein guter Spider-Man. Nee, den meinte ich nicht. Ich meinte The Amazing Spider-Man 2 war besser als der erste. Ich finde sogar The Amazing Spider-Man 2 den besten Spider-Man-Film. Was? Der mit Jamie Foxx? Ja. Der war grauenvoll. Scheinlich nicht. Du hast keine Ahnung. Aber das ist uncool.
Das ist uncool.
Lass mich da mal eine Minderheitsmeinung einnehmen.
Weißt du nicht, ob das eine Minderheitsmeinung ist?
Ich glaube schon.
So eine uncoole Nein-Gag-Minderheitsmeinung.
Ich glaube nicht, viele fanden den ersten wesentlich besser als den zweiten.
Mir hat der gefallen.
Ich fand, der Film hatte Eier, dass am Ende...
Einfach mal ein teils Film zu machen.
Das hat Wastrauma auch mal Eier.
Guten Film kann jeder. Sehr gut, aber am Ende Emma Watson stirbt, fand ich einen coolen Move. Dass der Green Goblin dann nochmal kommt, fand ich eigentlich ganz geil, habe ich nicht mehr mit erwartet. Ich gebe auch von diesen Superhelden-Filmen jetzt nicht mit filmkritischen Sachen daran, mit so Feuilleton-Gelaber. Weil ich finde, diese Maßstäbe kann man nicht ansetzen. Kann man bei The Dark Knight ansetzen. Aber sonst habe ich das nie erwartet bei Superheldenfilmen, dass da irgendwie Charaktertiefe oder so reinkommt. Ich finde, du hattest bei den X-Men-Filmen eine coole Charaktertiefe, du hattest bei Watchmen solche Sachen. Ich finde, die Comics haben auch die Charaktertiefe, aber die Filme haben es oft nicht. Warum nicht? Bei manchen gelingt es ja auch, das zu übertragen. Ich finde, du hast bei vielen Filmen, kannst du es dir erlauben, mit einem Feuilleton-Auge drauf zuzuschauen, du musst nicht mehr über diese uralte Ist ja nur ein Actionfilm, deswegen Gehirn aus, das ist die dümmste Argumente, das es überhaupt gibt. Bei guten Actionfilmen muss man eben nicht das Gehirn ausmachen, das macht sich zu guten Actionfilmen und man kann sie zwar schon genießen auf einer Oberflächenebene, man kann aber trotzdem auch tiefgründige Narrativen gut verfolgen. Auf jeden Fall, ja, aber ich sage nur, dass ich mich nicht mit die Heranforderungen angelegt habe, aus welchen Gründen auch immer. Nur wenn du die anlegst, dann verstehe ich auch nicht, warum du Spider-Man 1 jetzt so viel besser fandest als die Amazing Spider-Man 2. Weil ich finde, du kannst bei beiden nicht mit der, man muss auch mal nachdenken, nur mal kommen. Nee, du musst nicht mal nachdenken, aber du bist halt irgendwie involviert und du hast eine gute Charakterzeichnung. Hat mir einfach gut gefallen. Ich finde sowieso immer die ersten Teile von Superheldenfilmen finde ich persönlich am interessantesten. Ich finde es auch immer interessanter, wie Filme anfangen, als wie Filme aufhören. Aber das ist ja auch immer so interessant. Man hat ja, weil, sagen wir mal, du schaust 80% der Filme, die du schaust bis zum Ende an. Das heisst, du hast in deinem Leben schon wesentlich mehr Anfänge von
Filmen als Enden von Filmen
gesehen. Das heißt, deine gesamte Filmwahrnehmung...
Auch Enden von Filmen habe ich selten gesehen.
Das heißt, deine gesamte Filmwahrnehmung,
auch bei Büchern oder bei Musik,
du hast immer den Anfang und irgendwann
denkst du dir, ach scheiße, hör auf. Das heißt, du hast viel mehr
den Anfang mitbekommen.
Was ist der beste Filmanfang, würde ich dich da mal gerne
fragen.
There Will Be Blood ist der beste Film, hat auch einen sehr guten Film-Anfang, würde ich sagen. Ansonsten Magnolia, auch sehr gut angefangen und Darkwing Duck, Teil zwei, tatsächlich. Und beste Filmende? Beste Filmende ist Seven, würde ich sagen. Aber ich weiß nicht, ich müsste länger drüber nachdenken, weil es nur so ein bisschen einfach in die Tüte gesprochen. Falls ihr mehr Filmtalk von uns hören wollt, dann schaut doch mal vorbei bei unserem neu gestarteten Filmpodcast, der heisst nämlich Uncut. Und den starten wir in, glaube ich, sieben Jahren auf diesem Kanal. In vier zu drei vor allem auch. Bleibt jetzt nach dem Podcast einfach dran, dann könnt ihr eure Adresse nennen und dann klickt eure Informationen. Unsere Kollegen Burrentin und Beffan, erzähl euch dann, wann ihr mit dem Erscheinen rechnen müsst. Ja. Wollen wir schon mal eigentlich Everything is a Podcast anteasen? Nee. Nee, okay. Übernächste Folge vielleicht. Alles klar. Haben wir schon mal angefangen und haben, glaube ich, in dem Podcast behauptet, wir würden in der nächsten Folge mehr vorraten, haben es aber nicht getan. Seitdem haben wir nie wieder was verraten, jetzt wieder ein bisschen.
Ich habe jetzt wieder weniger.
Eine ganz uncool Spannungskurve, die einen schon verliert, einfach nach dem ersten Drittel.
Ja.
Ja, cool, danke dir.
Ich denke, aus diesen beiden Sachen können wir jetzt viel rausholen.
Du hast ein bisschen was über Filme verraten, finde ich interessant.
Dankeschön.
Hau rein, bis zum nächsten Mal, macht's gut, ihr Lieben. Und wir heben ab.